mi mayor aventura a nivel profesional
empezó justo aquí en este auditorio hace
un año marzo del 2020 muchos de ustedes
estaban aquí conmigo fue cuando en
méxico se declaró la pandemia
recuerdo que estábamos en un momento de
emergencia
nos dijeron que las clases iban a
continuar de manera virtual
en ese momento mi rol en la universidad
era estar al frente de los proyectos de
educación en línea por lo tanto la
noticia imagínense pues cayó como bomba
yo me sentí como que me cayó un balde de
agua fría
y me imaginaba como que se cerraba el
portón de la universidad y en mis manos
tenía el portal la llave del portal
digital para que todos ustedes alumnos
que están aquí y profesores pudieran
continuar con sus clases a distancia
fue un momento histórico
y aunque ustedes y yo no nos lo
imaginábamos estábamos dando un gran
paso un paso a la educación emergente a
la educación híbrida
y hablando de historia les traigo esta
imagen
esta imagen es de una postal que
dibujaron en el año 1900 una empresa
alemana que se dedicaba a fabricar
chocolates y hacer postales y entonces
en este año 1900 imaginaron cómo sería
la vida cotidiana en el siglo 21
esta es el aula de clases es la
universidad que ellos se imaginaban que
así iba a ser 100 años adelante yo les
pregunto sus salones de clase se parecen
a éstos
no verdad si se fijan tenemos un
profesor que está seleccionando unos
libros un contenido para que los alumnos
estudian y lo mete en esa máquina
extraña para que se transforme en
información que viaja a través de esos
cables y de esos audífonos que tienen
los alumnos fíjense cómo es una
comunicación unidireccional un solo
sentido el auditivo los alumnos están de
manera pasiva estudiando no vemos que
interactúen entre ellos o que hagan
trabajo en equipo
entonces quiero preguntarles hemos
superado esta visión como hemos llegado
hasta aquí les tengo una buena noticia
hoy estamos viviendo el mejor momento de
la educación hoy tenemos la mejor
educación de la historia y les voy a
decir por qué porque es una educación
digital tenemos acceso a la información
a través de internet de la nube tenemos
múltiples maneras de comunicarnos y de
colaborar con nuestros compañeros con
nuestros profesores es una educación que
favorece los cinco sentidos y que nos
involucra y yo creo que este paso que lo
hemos dado entre todos ha sido gracias
al compromiso y al esfuerzo de los
profesores y de los alumnos y por eso
todos ustedes se merecen un gran aplauso
antes de la pandemia las universidades
ya pensaban cómo iba a crecer la
educación en línea les platico que el
año pasado el 2020 la industria de la
educación a distancia aumentó más del
100 por ciento y se espera que en los
próximos 5 años aumente todavía más
algunos países abrazaron la innovación
desde antes de la pandemia les voy a
citar dos ejemplos
finlandia y singapur finlandia tiene un
modelo educativo reconocido famoso por
la educación de la escuela única donde
le dan la misma oportunidad de educación
a todos los alumnos y tiene los maestros
más preparados
también su modelo educativo favorece la
educación a través de proyectos singapur
es un país que de repente nos dio la
sorpresa ustedes habían escuchado de que
singapur era de las principales
potencias en educación
bueno pues que creen que ya dio el
brinco y ellos han abrazado la
innovación gracias a la educación en
base a prototipos quienes ustedes aquí
estudian ingeniería alguna ingeniería
bueno a ver ingenieros imagínense que
van a diseñar un nuevo sistema de riego
su clase consiste en diseñar ese
prototipo entonces el modelo educativo
se base en eso en que los alumnos
experimenten ya no se trata de estar de
manera pasiva como lo vimos en la lámina
se trata de involucrarse y eso es lo que
queremos de ustedes alumnos involucren
se involucren en el proceso pidan ayuda
a sus profesores los profesores ahora
tienen este rol y están ansiosos por
guiarlos por darles sus experiencias por
darles herramientas
entonces pues estamos hablando de países
que se adelantaron que han pensado en la
innovación de dónde viene innovación
tiene su raíz latina en innovación qué
quiere decir descubrir lo que ya vive
dentro y desde esa novedad interior
remover lo exterior hasta transformarlo
por lo tanto innovación no es hacer a un
lado lo que ya tenemos innovación es
abrazar lo nuevo y mantener lo que el
pasado nos ha funcionado
por eso la charla de este día pues es si
es el fin de la escuela
ustedes piensan que ya se acabó en la
escuela
les tengo tres preguntas incómodas
primera pregunta
es el fin de la escuela
segunda pregunta todavía necesitamos
estudiar para tener un título
universitario
tercer pregunta
van a desaparecer los profesores
están difíciles las preguntas verdad la
primera pregunta se responde con este
correo electrónico que recibí de un
alumno hace tres semanas se los voy a
leer maestra ana gracias por mi
calificación esta tarea me ayudó a
reflexionar cuánto extraño las clases mi
salón mis amigos
neta que es verdad eso de que nadie sabe
lo que tiene hasta que lo pierde y pues
yo espero yo espero no perderlo para
siempre porque tipo que me daba mucha
inspiración ver a mis amigos echándole
los kilos a los trabajos me ayudaba un
buen voltear a ver a mis compañeras
dando su 100% y siento que me falta
mucho aliento de mis propios
pensé que iba a disfrutar tomar clases
en pijama dos semestres seguidos pero ya
basta necesito las clases ponerme los
jeans y conectar mi compu en la
cafetería mientras me río con mi banda
en cuanto sepa me avisa cuando volvemos
por fa
esta vez le juro que seré el más puntual
bueno
la escuela este es el lugar que nos
ayuda a ser personas ese es el lugar
donde encontramos a nuestros amigos es
ese punto de encuentro es donde
aprendemos a socializar es donde
aprendemos a trabajar en equipo es donde
nos llevamos las mejores experiencias de
nuestra juventud quien ya quiere
regresar a clases levante su mano
chicos los estamos esperando no es el
fin de la escuela es el relanzamiento de
la escuela es su transformación no vamos
a regresar al mismo tipo de educación
que teníamos antes pasiva repetitiva
necesitamos renovar la educación y poner
en práctica todo lo que este año nos ha
enseñado
segunda pregunta todavía necesito
estudiar para tener un título
universitario
claro que sí
la sociedad nos pide demostrar que somos
competentes para desarrollar una
profesión yo puedo decir que soy muy
bueno pero creería en un subjetivismo
por lo tanto necesito que una
institución como ésta me avale que yo
soy un profesional competente y para que
esta institución pueda seguir
desempeñando esta función necesita
transformarse subirnos a la educación
híbrida para seguir ofreciendo educación
de vanguardia
y bueno la tercera pregunta es el rol
del profesor
para que queremos a los profesores si ya
tenemos todo en internet podemos
aprender un tema de youtube en 5 minutos
un tutorial nos explica cómo despejar
una ecuación para que queremos seguir
teniendo a los profesores
bueno los profesores ahora tienen un rol
muy importante más importante que nunca
el rol del acompañamiento porque los
profesores tienen una inteligencia como
la tuya y la mía una inteligencia humana
no una inteligencia artificial hoy los
necesitamos más que nunca que estén ahí
acompañándonos en el proceso
acompañándonos compartiendo nos sus
experiencias guiándonos orientándonos el
rol del profesor no desaparece se
transforma al igual que tu propio error
bueno entonces finalmente es el fin de
la escuela no es el relanzamiento de una
nueva educación la educación emergente
que implica la educación digital la
educación personalizada la educación
híbrida
a todo ese conjunto le llamamos
educación emergente que es la mejor de
la historia y que ha llegado para
quedarse
yo les invito a que nos sumemos a esta
nueva era de la educación
emergen